well it's not a surprise it's not a
surprise but it's no less outrageous no
less of a bad omen of things to come
that Cavanaugh joined the liberal
justices on the Supreme Court yesterday
to block a case that could have given
States the right to defund Planned
Parenthood Cavanaugh Roberts and the
Liberals but I guess I may be repeating
myself they're left in place to lower
court opinions that said that states
violate federal law when they terminate
Medicaid contracts with Planned
Parenthood affiliates now only four
justices are needed to grant a hearing
on a case because that's all that was at
stake here was just let's let's let's
give him a hearing let's let's let's
look at this case so Kavanaugh could
have been the decisive vote in that case
it's not as though the game was already
set because of Roberts so Kavanaugh just
joined him for PR purposes
I heard someone said that on Twitter
they said well maybe it was just because
Roberts was already doing that and it
didn't matter no they only need four you
only need four to agree to give a
hearing on something so his his vote was
decisive and he sided with the Liberals
it's it is now very hard to see
Kavanaugh voting to overturn Roe it was
already and there were those of us who
warned of this back when he was
nominated that it was already far from a
slam dunk that he would vote to overturn
Roe but now at this point it's it's
really hard to see it it's hard to see
them even allowing a case like that to
be heard in the first place because I
think sometimes people forget that an
order for four row in order for there to
be a vote on Roe first you have to have
a case challenging Roe that makes its
way its way all the way up to the
Supreme Court and then the Supreme Court
justices have to agree to hear it in the
first place
we know that the liberal justices would
never agree to it and now I think we've
got a pretty good idea of where Roberts
and Cavanaugh would fall on that and
this isn't even an abortion rights case
abortion rights I put
scare quotes around it this is just a
case about the rights of individuals to
not have their tax money go to abortion
conglomerates theoretically a a
pro-abortion person if they cared at all
about Liberty and I know that if you
care about Liberty you're not going to
be pro-abortion but if there was anyone
who's pretends to be more libertarian
minded but for some reason doesn't
understand how that concept how that
principle should extend to the unborn
they should still be in favor of
allowing States to defund because that's
what this is all about this isn't this
is about should Planned Parenthood that
business that earns over a billion
dollars or that is that's worth over a
billion dollars should it continue to
receive funds from the state so we know
where Cavanaugh stands on that meanwhile
the the new Congress with the Democrat
controlled house will be taking over in
January I think their first I think
they'll be in session on January third I
believe
and guess what hasn't gotten done well a
lot of things haven't gotten done
actually the wall for one there's no
wall Obamacare is still in place the
budget isn't balanced fiscal
responsibility was not established but
on top of that list on top of that
extensive list of failures I think at
the very top of that list is going to be
the fact that Planned Parenthood was
never defunded and it's actually it's
not enough to say that Planned
Parenthood was never defunded it's it's
actually a lot worse than that the truth
is the truth is that Planned Parenthood
was actively funded it wasn't just not
defunded it was funded the choice was
made by this Republican Congress - it
was made again and again and again to
actively fund Planned Parenthood and
that choice was also signed off by the
president so it really seems like
Planned Parenthood will never be
defunded this institution that kills
three hundred and thirty thousand humans
a year will continue to be funded by the
government
and do you know why I think you must
know why because there is no pro-life
party there isn't there isn't even a pro
Liberty party because you only need to
be in favor of Liberty like I said you
could be lukewarm on life you could say
yeah take it or leave it life I don't
know but if you care about freedom if
you care about economic freedom let's
say because if you care about freedom in
general then obviously you're gonna care
about life because you can't have
freedom without life but let's say
you're you're one of those socially
liberal types but you you you claim to
care about economic freedom well in that
case you would say or you should say if
you really are economic if you care
about economic freedom you would say
it's obviously tyrannical to force
people to fund this this company this
company that half of the country detests
and loads and wants nothing to do with
so we don't have a party that cares
about I met we don't have a party that
cares about that cares about pro-life we
don't have a party that cares about
economic freedom
which is why we gave it control of the
entire government and it couldn't even
get this job done instead we get Planned
Parenthood funding and we get a Supreme
Court justice who won't even let us hear
a case that might defund it I think we
need to understand something else if we
if we don't already understand this for
most Republicans okay abortion and
Planned Parenthood and all of the issues
attached to it abortion and all that
means it is a great issue for them issue
okay for Republicans it's not a problem
that they want to get rid of it's not an
evil to them it is an issue and it's
great because it can be used to convince
people to vote for them but if abortion
ever goes away or Planned Parenthood
funding ever goes away then they no
longer have that issue anymore now you
know in a sense they do because they
could argue that well the other guys
want to reinstate these things so you
got to put us in to stop them but that
our that's never as strong as being able
say there's this terrible thing
happening we need to get rid of it and
were the only ones who will do that so
they have they want this they have this
issue they want it it is it is
advantageous to them they could care
less about the content of the issue they
could care less about solving any
problem they don't they could care less
about stopping it worse than that they
don't want to stop it they want the
issue and if that much isn't clear to
you by now I don't know what will ever
make it clear there are some exceptions
to this rule you know this is this is
not true of of every Republican
necessarily but it is true of most of
them they don't care about this and
that's why I don't see any changes in
the in the near future I don't see any
way that any of this changes in the near
future and if we can't get you know if
we if we can't get Planned Parenthood
defunding with a Republican Senate and a
Republican House and and a Republican
president and two Republican a two
recent Republican appointees is
supposedly five conservative supreme
supreme court justices supposedly if we
if we can't get it done that way we
can't get it done through the judiciary
we can't get it done through through
Congress then how's it gonna happen I
don't see it happening at a certain
point we need to figure out as
pro-lifers how and when and if we are
ever going to hold these people
accountable you know when when are we
ever going to hold them accountable
because they never do what they say
they're going to do and then and then we
said we're gonna hold you accountable
for this come election time but then
they say no you can't hold us
accountable because if you do that then
the other guys might get in there and
they're definitely not going to do what
you want them to do
so you might as well roll the dice on us
we're your best chance well I don't even
think they're that anymore you know the
problem with the problem with
conservatives and and pro lifers
especially but conservatives in general
is that we are we are crumb eaters we
eat the crumbs that are thrown to us
we're satisfied with whatever little
crumbs are thrown to us by the people
that we elect and put in power and that
we support with our votes we are
satisfied with so even now everything
that I'm saying right now I know there
are people are gonna say well well yeah
but we got tax cuts yeah you know we
didn't to fund Planned Parenthood we
didn't get rid of Obamacare we don't
have the wall you know there's no fiscal
responsibility we still got the massive
deficits but but we got we got tax cuts
right and we you know reduced
regulations here and there okay great
fantastic that's that's awesome I'm I'm
very happy about that we got we got tax
cuts and reduced regulations not saying
that stuff isn't important but that's
easy
any Republican will do that that's
that's that's nothing for considering
all of the power that Republicans had
for for two years they controlled the
entire government and this is what we
did a tax cut bill and reduce a few
regulations and people are happy with
that you're satisfied with that all of
the the major important significant
things that we put them in there to do
they are not did not have not done
repeal Obamacare didn't happen get the
wall done didn't it's not even beginning
to happen defund Planned Parenthood not
happening and oh yeah get us construct
get us Supreme Court justices that are
actual constitutionalists and actual
conservatives give you that too and
apparently it's looking like that didn't
happen either so it is a huge failure on
all of these fronts
we're supposed to be happy because of
tax cuts and it and what boggles my mind
is that some conservatives apparently
are happy with that that's nothing that
is nothing we need to start demanding a
lot more and expecting a lot more and
holding people accountable when it
doesn't happen all right
here's something interesting mark Perry
an economics professor shared shared
something on his Twitter yesterday
it's from the Bureau of Labor Statistics
and it lists the top twenty most
dangerous jobs based on fatal injury per
100,000 workers I want to read well I
got to pull this up I'm going to read
some of these to you these are the most
dangerous jobs in America the most
recent tally anyway
of the most dangerous jobs in America so
we have number one logging workers that
is 95% male so I want you to as I read
these jobs I want you to notice if
there's anything that you know that they
all have in common so number one logging
workers the most the most dangerous the
most fatal job in America 95% male
phishing workers 99.9 percent male
number three aircraft pilots ninety four
point eight percent male and as someone
with a fear of flying the fact that
aircraft pilot is the third most
dangerous job in America makes me
extremely uncomfortable
number four roofers 91.4% male refuse
collectors 98 percent male truck drivers
ninety four percent male iron and steel
workers 98 percent male farmers and
ranchers seventy five percent male
agricultural workers 79 percent male and
then it goes on and then the the 20th
most dangerous
job is mining and that is 99.9% male so
I bring this up just so that this is
something that you could keep in mind
when people complain about the supposed
supposed wage gap a wage gap that all
but disappears of course when you look
at comparable jobs and comparable levels
of skill and occasionally
the way they get that wage gap figure
the seventy five seventy five cents on
the dollar that women make or whatever
it is the way they get it is too broadly
compared all men in the workforce to all
women without at all accounting for the
actual jobs being done so the 75 cents
on a dollar figure is of course
meaningless but if you were wondering
where it comes from this should give you
an idea if you were wondering oh okay
fine we're not we're not taking to
account the jobs they're doing the skill
level training any of that hours work
that doesn't take into account but still
there is this difference when you lump
everything together so why do we have
that difference it's because men do the
more dangerous the more physically
demanding jobs and they are rewarded
accordingly
for comparison's sake there are some
jobs that are dominated by women so
according to USA Today here are some of
the jobs that are dominated by women
public relations specialists social and
community service manager production
planning and expediting clerks parking
enforcement workers technical writers
non farm animal caretakers fabric and
apparel pattern makers writers and
authors opticians bakers graders and
sorters public relations managers
pharmacists Natural Science managers and
veterinarians that is the number one a
female dominated field so those are all
jobs that require skill those are most
of them important jobs but none of them
are dangerous
none of them are anywhere near as
physically demanding
and so this tells us why this difference
exists on top of other reasons two men
tend to work more hours as well
men are more willing to work overtime
men are more willing to work on weekends
I think I also read the men are more
willing to travel you know further for a
job and that goes down to it's just a
matter of priorities you know women tend
to prioritize other things like their
families and their relationships and
that's good that's a positive thing it's
good that women value those men as men
we should value those things more than a
lot of us apparently do but not to say
that people who work a lot of hours
don't value their families but I'm
saying you know magenta put more of a
value on sort of career ambition and
succeeding in the job and women can put
more value on the family and the thing
is the family is the more important
thing so they've got that one right and
men are simply more willing to work
these jobs if you look at how dominated
these fields are by men logging fishing
mining mining is a 99.9 percent male job
but also you know it pays pretty well
most of the time well why is it 99.9
percent males at 99.9 percent male
because women are excluded because women
are getting you've got a whole bunch of
women that just really want to work in
the mines but they aren't they aren't
they are allowed to long-haul truck
drivers
that's a 94 percent male occupation is
it because all these women are clamoring
to be long-haul truck drivers but they
aren't allowed to or is it just that
women for the most part have no interest
at all in doing those jobs I think
that's the reason and so that's why they
aren't paid the same all right last but
not least some sad news one of the great
power couples in the world today is
splitting up and i hate's have to tell
you this according to the Irish Post an
woman who married the ghost of a 300
year old pirate claims that the couple
has now split up
Amanda Teague married a Haitian pirate
named Jack earlier this year I don't
know if you remember hearing that
stories a great it was at the time
anyway it was a great romantic story the
wedding took place on board a boat in
international waters off the Irish coast
and everything seemed to be going well
at first but now and it you know hasn't
even been what hasn't been a year and
now apparently they're breaking up which
is which is really the second bad break
for Jack because he was executed on the
high seas in the 1700s so he's executed
he's dead he's a ghost he finally finds
love and now that is even falling apart
pretty sad in fact I heard that they
split up after a bad argument I I guess
they just weren't soul mateys
but you know I hear I hear he's hooking
up with someone else now and the fact is
that relationship has been on the last
leg for a while so they tried to patch
it up but just didn't work
suppose the the romance was dead in
their relationship it was hard to
because she wanted him to talk more but
he wouldn't say boo plus I mean he could
never set foot in their living room
which was hard but I'm sure he'll do
fine on the dating scene because you
know he's a he's a good-looking ghost
and as I say if you got it haunted
ghouls just want to have fun if you know
what I mean and the thing is they would
get into fights because the Pirates
parrot his ghost parrot would poop all
over the place and his wife would say
why is the parrot doing that and the
pirate would say well hey look it's
totally parrot normal that was a stretch
I I was trying to go for paranormal but
parrot no just it didn't work all right
um I gotta just I gotta leave it there I
could go on for another five minutes
with the pub by the way soul mate II was
that's a that is a double pun because
you got the matey for the for the
Pirates soul s Oh
ul so because he's dead so you see that
it's a double pun and yeah alright I'll
talk to you tomorrow have a great day
Godspeed